all right hey you guys doing a movie
retrospective yeah going back to some
50s sci-fi we don't do a lot of that on
this show 50 sci-fi man you're always
risking it
that's one of the better ones i mean
not as good as you know like in uh
forbidden planet
but okay it's pretty good
yeah i kind of feel like this is maybe a
b or c tier uh as far as like 50s go but
i love the gimmick
and i love the monster yeah
uh i haven't read a couple of them yeah
i mean well you know the monster i'm
talking but the one that was on the
cover of the misfits album yeah
my dad my dad showed me this to me uh
showed this to me when i was a kid on
television yeah yeah that's my first
that must been way back in the 70s i was
probably about six seven maybe eight
and uh that was probably six or seven it
scared me i couldn't see that yeah this
one scared me that dude got absorbed by
the dab jellyfish that's [ __ ] up if
you think about it yeah the big spider
rat and everything and
but my dad loved this movie when he was
a kid
this is like the best thing going yeah
this came out in
1959 yeah uh and it's called the angry
red planet yeah
i think it initially was supposed to be
called invasion of mars and i've also
seen it called journey to planet four
but i think most people know it's the
angry red planet the original version i
think was in black and white it was it
wasn't um now the the scenes that they
shot on mars because this has kind of
like a gimmick which a lot of 50s sci-fi
did called cinemagic yeah um where i'll
kind of describe it in a little bit as
much as i like understand what they did
but all the scenes on mars were shot in
black and white because that was cheaper
but the stuff where they were inside the
spacecraft and on earth and [ __ ] like
that that was all like color that was
like technicolor so yeah because i was
watching it the whole time and i'm like
wait was this whole thing shot in black
and white and then it was colorized
later because i said it doesn't look
like it was colorized but it was like
all the earth [ __ ] was uh was actually
originally shot in color it was just the
mars [ __ ] it was black it was shot in
black and white and then they did a
process on it too make it red to tint it
red okay i got you yeah i thought the
whole thing because i've seen a lot of
stills from this movie in black and
white and i thought it was a black and
white movie i thought it had been
colorized modern
i thought so too but it's like hard to
tell right
it looks okay
yeah i mean i thought it looked pretty
nice to be honest with you like the
color and stuff for the time it was it
was pretty good oh yeah and uh now you
know we're not like i said this is baby
b or c tier
this isn't forbidden planet i mean
forbidden planet is [ __ ] top notch i
mean that's
better than an old star trek episode the
way it is you know something to say
that's not saying much but fred platt it
looked really good what are you talking
about old star trek episodes were off
yeah
but uh [ __ ] that was the star wars of
the day for a forbidden planet
it looks good the last time i saw it it
still looked good
yeah we should probably get around to
doing that one because i do want to get
into doing more 50 sci-fi like it's not
my favorite genre yeah and i've seen a
lot of bad 50s sci-fi because of being
uh you know an mst fan and they do a lot
of uh 50s i don't think they ever did
this one um but
uh yeah so i would say top notch 50s war
of the worlds and there's that goddamn
phone
i would say be war of the worlds and
forbidden planet
oh yeah definitely and i don't think
anybody would argue with you on that
score earth stood still
yeah that's a good one too yeah but
that's more about writing than it is
sci-fi or do you mean but uh more about
writing than it is special effects well
i kind of feel like the problem too and
this uh movie suffers from it a tad also
is that 50 sci-fi usually it was
marketed toward kids
uh so it was cheap like they produced
them kind of cheaply and so it's like
they would have one really cool gimmick
or really cool monster or really cool
scene or something like that and then
they had to pad out the rest of the
runtime with
stuff that wasn't that expensive to film
talking so it's yeah it's gonna be like
people standing around in rooms talking
to one another about the problem that
they're solving yeah and uh this one
totally does have that i will say this
movie it's not that long i think it's uh
there's a couple different cuts of it
yeah like one of them is 84 minutes one
is 87 minutes but i will say like the
first i don't even know if it's the
first half but like the first third of
it is pretty slow it takes them like a
while
i mean for a while they're just kind of
like wandering around in the rocket ship
like before they actually get out and
like get on mars and all the crazy like
interesting [ __ ] starts to happen and
the rocket ship is not impressive
well i think what they did and i saw
this in other movies too like i think i
also saw this in phantom planet which i
can't remember what year that came out i
think it might have been a couple years
before this but that one wasn't black
and white i think they just draw like
little cartoons of rocket ships and then
like you know kind of put them over the
cell like an animation cell type
situation interestingly too in this
movie angry red planet all the [ __ ] you
see on mars was all like hand-drawn
okay that was one of the um that was one
of the things that was supposed like
cinematic is that oh we found this super
cheap way to
film like this sci-fi kind of [ __ ] is
like basically they'll do the
backgrounds like you would do an
animated film
and then you would just kind of like lay
the actors over it kind of thing you
know what i'm saying and then because
this one was like tinted and they
actually they [ __ ] it up that it
didn't come out the way they were
intending but they thought it looked
cool so they're like all right [ __ ] it
you know what i mean because it came out
okay uh but yeah so there was that now
this was directed by
ib melchior now i knew that name
he's actually a danish writer and he
worked on a bunch of sci-fi i think um
probably one of the ones that
i remember seeing his name on was
reptilicus that danish godzilla movie
yeah they did that on mst also
not a great movie not terrible though um
i will say stale
yes
it was a little uh yeah he also i think
probably his best known one other than
this is probably robinson crusoe on mars
which actually i remember liking that
yeah which i think a lot of people did i
think a lot of people did i haven't seen
in a long time
so basically the story what happens in
angry angry angry grey planet
the angry purple planet i don't [ __ ]
know angry red planet we were take
because uh pookie was watching this with
us so we kept like teasing her that the
planet was full of angry red pokeys
yeah
and she was watching it she was watching
it because i think the i think the the
rat bat spider monster kind of freaked
her out a little bit she's like what the
[ __ ] is that because her little ears
flat yeah she saw the eyes and the face
she sees faces and stuff she's like
what's that thing it looks like a big
giant mouthy but yeah
uh but yeah so basically what you have i
didn't realize you remembered this i
didn't because i don't think i'd ever
seen this movie because you saw it as a
kid with your dad yeah
is a lot of this movie is actually told
in flashback right i kind of wish they
hadn't done that because
you know now you know that like well at
least two of the people are gonna
survive right you know everybody not
everybody's gonna die so a lot of the
sus the suspense is gone yeah i know why
they did that though they have to front
load it with a bunch of talking well
yeah of course because they have to hold
back yeah you know what i mean they have
to wait like for the monster for the
monsters that's what they're doing if
not it would be very short which is dumb
they should have never done that yeah
you need to get people involved like in
the [ __ ] like right away 50s thinking
put more monsters in it give them their
money's worth you know they're like we
can't afford more money they could
though all they had to do is just make
the scenes longer with the rat spider
and just the rat spider did some could
do some more stuff
you could and then the other thing that
you know what i mean there there's there
were opportunities to do a lot more
interaction you probably could have got
an extra 20 minutes of monsters they
probably could to be honest with you
they just didn't know how to film action
i mean because once the monsters were
made like you said you could just do
more [ __ ] with them rather than having
because this actually does open
with your standard 50s monster movie
group of old white dudes right sitting
around a table talking about uh they had
this manned mission to mars i don't know
what year it was supposed to be did they
say no um
i think well i mean that because usually
you see a movie that's supposed to be
like oh it's the 80s it's like the
future we're going to mars and [ __ ] like
that but i don't know if they said it
was like the future or anything the
drawing it did get some [ __ ] right the
drawings of the rockets actually looked
pretty good yeah that's what i yeah i
thought and they did kind of call it i
used to laugh that the 50s rockets
always landed on their tails yeah now
that we got elon musk that [ __ ]
yeah they land on their tails that's how
you do it well for a long time we did
think that was dumb because it's like
well the only reason they did that was
because like i said it was a drawing so
they were just kind of like
that and they would make a [ __ ] a
stupid set and they had to get go in and
out of it all the time and you know and
if you're going to travel in a rocket
back in these days rockets were
multi-staged and it just ended up with a
capsule
the the idea of you going to a place in
a rocket in a hole coming back in that
same bass [ __ ] rocket was an
impossibility so we we would laugh at
that but it's not impossible now
no but i mean like back then i'm
guessing like i said you know it's this
these are mostly like geared toward
little kids so i think they wouldn't
have really like grasped the
the nuances of you know we only have the
rocket to get us out of the earth's
atmosphere like once you're out there
you just need the capsule bit you know
what i mean it was a reach man to get
somewhere and back in a rocket back in
those days yeah it was more plausible if
they did like what you did on forbidden
planet they would travel around
to all these planets in a flying saucer
that made a whole lot more sense
because you're not confined to the
rocket concept yeah you know
yeah i mean i kind of feel like they
should have done more
like earthlings going places than
playing saucers and you know star trek
was kind of based and inspired on
forbidden planet with inspired it that's
why the enterprise is a [ __ ] flying
saucer it's a flying saucer with some
[ __ ]
with some [ __ ] on the back it started
it's a flying sauce
it's 50 stinking stuff yeah you know
yeah but that's cool that's i mean
that's an iconic [ __ ] design yeah but
yeah this just had your standard 50s
rocket that looks kind of like a tampon
applicator yeah or you know like a big
or a bic pen or something yeah but yeah
so uh okay so what happened there's a
manned mission to mars there's four uh
people on it and it apparently they okay
so like the the white guys on the ground
the white guys in suits on the ground
they lost contact with this ship so they
were assuming like something bad
happened or they're all dead or whatever
but then at the beginning of the movie
they find the the rocket kind of just
floating out in the atmosphere and
they're like well i'll be damned i don't
remember if they said like how long it
had been
but it had been a while they're just
like well we gotta go get that [ __ ] like
and see if they're still in there and
they bring the cat the rocket back to
the earth
and uh the first thing that comes out
like there's actually a woman scientist
on there named iris and she's a
biologist i think and she's kind of the
first one out and it's so [ __ ] funny
i was like this is so 50s it's so
[ __ ] funny she was one of like four
crews the other three were dudes
obviously but she comes out the thing
like they're leading her out because you
know it's like a tragic you know thing
that happened and all of the dudes that
are like the the military police and all
that were like the girl and they all
like run over there like [ __ ] the
radiation we're gonna go like see some
[ __ ] titties or whatever i don't know
what the [ __ ] it was just like really
funny so uh she lived and she seems to
be okay although she's pretty
traumatized and also the captain
tom banyan i think his name was uh he's
also alive but he's kind of [ __ ] up he
looks like he's got like some green
jello [ __ ] like all over his arms he got
blobbed he got blobbed essentially yeah
uh so yeah so that's like the beginning
part so they put him in the hospital to
see but they don't like quarantine him
or nothing they weren't like thinking
about that the 15 even though he clearly
brought like some alien jello back with
him yeah you would think that they would
just like contain that's like no boob
would touch him they would contain her
too yeah he won't worry about it they
were worried they're like whatever yeah
just make sure it's just getting
stronger
it's fine it's the 50s suck it up yeah
spray it
spray them back to eat on there yeah but
yeah so there's that so so he's kind of
like unconscious and like all blobbed
out or whatever i'm lying about spraying
don't you remember the [ __ ] star trek
the hypo was
yeah they sprayed it that's what they're
doing it's [ __ ] back team that's
fifty fixes everything fixes everything
you just kind of put it up there and
goes
there he goes there he goes
you can't high-tech man you can't
high-tech
so your irritable bowel syndrome is gone
your migraine is gone whatever the 50s
were a [ __ ] they were the [ __ ] trip
man
they were [ __ ] they were so
optimistic yeah
well they were working with what they
had so they were just extrapolating we
have this so therefore in the future
it'll be a be even better version of
this yeah you know the idea that they
didn't think that it was like a
completely different yeah things going
obsolete replacement well most people
don't other technologies you don't think
they didn't think like that but we don't
think that way no nobody does this like
i said well not nobody but like a couple
people do but right not that many
but yeah so
uh so he's all blobbed and he can't talk
so they don't really know what happened
because like all the tapes that they
made of like the voyage have been erased
uh but iris is okay she's just like
really traumatized and is having problem
trouble like remembering so they give
her
something like truth serum or something
like that she's kind of wigging out like
being a woman and stuff like in the
50s movie but
but eventually they do get enough out of
her like she remembers enough to like
tell them about what happened on the
voyage so then it goes into like a
flashback and i think there's one point
in there too where they kind of go back
to come back to the present again but
it's almost all a flashback yes and then
they they got it there's plenty of [ __ ]
be crazy scenes in there oh my god
there's a part where it basically it
says
this [ __ ] [ __ ] be crazy
this drug her up and we'll get some
sense out of her that's funny yeah that
was that's exactly what he said that's
what it meant though but that's that's
yeah [ __ ] be crazy so let's get what
the doctor said and we'll get some sense
out of her was kind of like yeah that's
that's what he meant yeah he just said
it like in a nicer way
we were watching that and i was just
gonna and i laughed and tom's like oh
okay [ __ ] be crazy but we have to
drag her to get some sense out of her
i'm like
yeah mean i will give this like it's
fairly progressive for 1959 for having
an actual like woman doctor that's a
biologist like on the ship who actually
ends up at the end spoiler alert like
kind of solving the problem like ends up
um figuring out what uh what cures the
the blob disease
that captain tom has so she does
actually do [ __ ] and she has agency but
there is still like you know it's still
1959 so she's still gonna get like you
know comments about her butt and [ __ ]
like that like on the [ __ ] they gave
her comments better but well um
okay kinda one of the yeah uh the
another thing that one of the the
bouncer guy i call him the bouncer i
can't remember he was what the [ __ ] did
he do on the ship he was like he was the
comic book he was the comic relief he
was jaylen i called him like i called
him i was like i'm just the bouncer
because he started like he was like a
brooklyn yeah i don't know what the [ __ ]
he was doing on there he had a regular
he was reading comic books and had a
freeze ray that he was really into yeah
and i mean it was a freeze ray is that
the coffee yeah okay and i've been so
into it he had it was named cleo yeah
and i'm clean and i'm pretty sure that
he probably
allegedly they probably [ __ ] it i mean
it was that it was that level it was it
was more 50s thinking yeah the world
there's a lot of world war ii in this oh
yeah big time world war ii had a heavy
influence on these people
it's
it's it's a man portable man pack ray
gun okay that shoots out a [ __ ] blast
of freeze blast
well that's a futuristic sci-fi
interpretation of a flamethrower a world
war ii flame yeah it's just in that it's
so high-tech that it's not hot it's not
cold
not real not real
creative but
okay i mean technically it doesn't shoot
out anything you don't it just makes an
annoying beeping sound yeah but you know
that's kind of cool because that's way a
laser is you don't really see the beam
that's the [ __ ] impact of [ __ ]
but like i said also very economical
yeah it can move filming purposes yeah
and it kind of looks like a browning
1919 [ __ ] machine gun with a butt
stock on it and a and a man pack on the
back of it with a cord and it has a the
sight is just a damn aircraft [ __ ]
ring with a [ __ ] yeah crosshair in it
it doesn't have a front seat i mean yeah
they just like built it yeah it's just
hard though
at the end it has like a thumb hole
stock and everything looks like almost
kind of like some of the dragon off it's
kind of like a
[Laughter]
[ __ ] rest the rat spider attacks him
and it [ __ ] blows the irises out of
the [ __ ]
race it's actually that was actually the
best part of the movie
and that was the part where i said if
i'd seen this when i was a little kid i
would have [ __ ] my pants at that that's
scary-looking yeah i think it's kind of
especially back in those days if you
were like a little kid yeah especially
back in those days i felt so bad for
like the rap bad spider creature the red
spider in reality was probably about the
size of a football with legs on it it
was a marionette yeah it was like a
marionette yeah and you could tell that
but but i think that's cool though yeah
like and the fact that they shot it like
through that weird filter and like all
the red and like the weird polarization
and stuff it actually gave it a really
weird like otherworldly yeah and because
it moved like a marionette kind of like
that
and had like weird crab legs right and
it was kind of like you know what it
reminded me of i know you didn't see
this movie but i reviewed a movie like
not too long ago called possum it's like
a british movie about this super creepy
um like ventriloquist or yeah like a
puppeteer and he had a puppet that was
like a spider like spider legs but with
like kind of a mannequin head on it yeah
and it kind of reminded me of that it's
like it has like a weird like unsettling
this is the look to it funny thing you
know jenny was saying well you know they
had to save these
monster scenes because of the money
i think they thought so but i don't
think they really thought it through
because
when you the padding you have to pay
these people to do acting and to show up
and to commute there to the [ __ ]
studio although maybe that's part of it
part of it was you had to pay actors
that might have because it's a grift
yeah um
but you could have saved your money by
getting rid of a couple of the
of the actors
and streamlined the story down to where
it was mostly monsters
and shot them all on the same screen in
a shorter period of time and had a movie
with nothing but just monster jam-packed
full of [ __ ] monsters
because making marionettes you know
not that expensive no and the background
was just painted yeah they said that
cost about 100 bucks yeah so
[Laughter]
had i been make producing this movie and
directing it it would have been mostly
monsters the kids would have [ __ ]
loved it
monster action and it would be basically
the first thing they do when they get to
mars is kill some [ __ ] they shoot some
[ __ ] plants with the damn death ray
and i'm like that's yeah i know they
show up
let's kill some [ __ ]
like i said they dick around on the
rocket ship for a while yeah and then
they're like looking out and there's
like vegetation on mars it was 1959
y'all like a lot of vegetation like a
jungle essentially and they're they're
saying [ __ ] like well there's all these
plants out there but they're not moving
like implying that there's no wind which
for some reason leads them to make a
very large logical leap that oh well
there must be some greater intelligence
controlling
the vegetation because it doesn't move
yeah there's all kinds of weird things
and i was just kind of like what what
happened in between those two
points i'm not really getting
i'm not getting that but anyway
uh so yeah there's all these [ __ ]
plants so they finally get off the ship
and the first thing they do is they find
like a plant they're like huh that's
interesting pow yeah yeah and then they
just kill it it works it's dead yeah and
then he sits there like he's a british
[Laughter]
this movie would have basically been
called
america [ __ ] yeah we're here to destroy
mars
we've been fighting monsters the whole
time america [ __ ] mars yeah america
where the shout a bit more like yeah
yeah yeah punchy yeah
but uh there was a um i could have made
this looking a lot better well yeah it
would have been a survival horror on
mars
and and it's because first thing they do
is they come off the rocket they shoot
the [ __ ] plants and little did they
know the plants are all in communication
with each other and they're animals
actually and they have intelligence so
they killed somebody's pookie and then
all the [ __ ]
the planet rises up against them and
then they have to survive it takes the
[ __ ] off yeah get out of the [ __ ]
planet and in the end you know just like
in this movie the aliens say you know
get the [ __ ] off of mars don't ever come
back here it's basically just stay on
your own [ __ ] planet we've been
watching blow your own [ __ ] up we've
been watching y'all y'all are [ __ ] bags
which is what the aliens are over there
yeah there is a city on this planet yeah
but i mean it's painted so they don't go
to it they just kind of like see it from
far away and they're like whoo neat and
then yeah they get it
they get attacked by a giant blob
monster and have to like run back to the
ship yeah i was doing this but what i
was gonna say like there's okay so
there's two things where we were saying
where we were saying about iris the
woman scientist um getting well because
the the bouncer jay leno guy did say
something about two moons like referring
to her but i'm pretty sure or her tits
could have been any other thing yeah so
there was that that was okay um that's
acceptable the her and captain tom were
in kind of like a little uh
thing like a little flirtation type [ __ ]
now he was played by i think his name's
gerald moore and i was like man i know
that dude he's really familiar and i was
like i must have seen him in some other
movie that was on mst and indeed i did
it was invasion usa not the chuck norris
one uh this one was like a cold war
like a russian infiltration one that
came out of 1952 and i knew him from
that but he's been in like a [ __ ] ton go
to his wikipedia page he's been he was
in all the movies like going back to the
40s but
one thing okay so he's like kind of he
has a huge forehead by the way
and i kept like pointing he looks a
little bit like um like um what's this
what's his ass uh
[ __ ] uh i'll think of it in a sec
humphrey bogart he looks a little bit
like that um but with a bigger forehead
and a little more rumply but um he was
like he was a little bit creepy in this
he's okay so her thing is that her name
is iris and she has like super red hair
so you're presuming that she's irish so
he just keeps calling her irish and she
kind of calls him out on it like why do
you keep calling like my name is iris
iris okay it's like i what are you
calling me my nationality or my name and
he says to her
when i call your name you'll know it
like that and i was just kind of like
[ __ ] you dude what the [ __ ] oh and also
but the funniest line what i was saying
about like the weird like sexual lines
and i was watching brandon tennold did a
review of this too and he also said the
same exact thing that i thought when i
was watching this
she's looking out the window like i
think this is before they land on mars
and she says something like
um talking about a dark tunnel like you
know i thought broadway was a dark
tunnel or something like that and he
says something to the effect of oh we
get back to earth like uh we'll explore
that dark tunnel together yeah i'm like
dude are you talking about her vagina
yeah because that's pretty much what it
sounded like yeah and i was glad that
like brandon tunnell backed me up
because he said the same thing are you
talking about her vagina like oh my god
that's exactly what i thought all the
damn innuendo
because i was
like wow that was really dirty for like
1959 because he said it like real scuzzy
and he was like kind of rubbed up on her
and stuff and i was just like oh my god
all right so so yeah so they dick around
the spaceship there's also a professor
by the way who has a van dyke and looks
like a little bit like the devil yeah
and uh well like i said you were saying
that like they could have had not so
many actors but i was like well i would
submit to you that they at least needed
like
the the love the two love interest
people who lived and then you needed
some more cannon fodder because you
needed like some other people to get
eaten by the monsters right yeah because
then there should have just been less
acting
yeah
stop with all the acting
and get killed because there are a few
scenes in this where they're just kind
of like hey we're gonna go out on mars
uh in a little while but we're just
gonna like hang out in here the problem
with the movie is that this basically
the story is very very basic and the
dialogue and the personal inner
interaction between the people is just
really kind of dumb there's not a lot of
content there
it'd have been better if it was just
like mission oriented let's get there
let's get [ __ ] up let's escape and get
the hell out more action
but
the 50s did not know how to shoot an
action movie there was no such thing as
an action movie really probably the
closest to an action movie would be a
western
background yeah like i said they didn't
have a lot of they really did put a lot
of like scenes of like unnecessary
scenes of like people talking to us i
guess that was the expectations of the
culture of the time too it was kind of a
theater vaudeville type base so you sit
around and make [ __ ] wise cracks and
joke around and
you know
talk about what it is you're gonna do
don't do it you're gonna talk about what
you're gonna do yeah you're like yeah
we're gonna go to mars okay we're going
to mars next week you know to go to mars
we have to do this and this and that's
we have to get them from something on
the shield or none of those [ __ ] bug
so how are you what are you getting
married you know that kind of [ __ ] that
kind of [ __ ] is in the [ __ ] 50s movie
you know well it's like like i said
characterization in movies like yeah you
have to do it because you want people to
like care about the characters but it
can be done like a lot more briefly than
just having to like sit around talking
about [ __ ] right for a long time but
i will say that once they actually get
out and you get like the crazy
mars [ __ ] it's actually pretty cool like
i said most of the backdrops uh were all
uh hand-painted like obviously they made
some of the plants because one of the
plants tries to eat iris uh and there's
that
but what they did was they shot those
parts in black and white and then they
did like a partial polarization on it so
some of the film went uh from negative
to or from the negative went to positive
so they just left it like that but then
they exposed it i think twice and they
[ __ ] it up because some of the some of
the um places went transparent which
actually wasn't supposed to happen but
then when they did the red tint over it
they thought it looked kind of cool so
if you look at it like you can see
because i noticed this when i was
watching it because i'm a graphic
designer so i know how some of this
stuff works but um
you could see like where the where some
of the [ __ ] was blown out like it was
red but then it was like yellow like a
really bright yellow like in some of the
whiter areas and that's what happened
they just like overexposed it but they
thought it looked cool so they were like
[ __ ] it we're just gonna leave it
artistic looking yeah i thought it looks
kind of cool so one like tie-dye in one
color once they get out but here's the
thing though i feel like they weren't on
mars long enough like they get out and
then they shoot a plant and then iris
almost gets eaten by another bigger
plant and then they're like okay well
let's go back to the ship i'm like
seriously don't go back to the ship come
on um you just got out here and then
they go out again
and then they find like a lake
and then they start boating into the
lake and they see the city and they're
like wow holy [ __ ] look at that
and then like this big huge blob
thing like a sea blob like a sea blob
like comes out and it has like a weird
like
it had like a weird filter feeding thing
on the front it looked like and it
actually because they were like well
[ __ ] now we gotta get out of the water
so they get out of the water but then
they're like oh the dude's amphibious
right and he just comes blobbing
like on the land after them and then it
tries to eat their ship yeah it
surrounds which i thought was actually
pretty cool so it's all like goopy and
[ __ ] and then like the the brooklyn the
brooklyn jay leno dude uh gets absorbed
yeah and actually if you think about it
this is pretty [ __ ] up because they
actually show like the blob kind of
pulsating and then like you can see his
little body in there like it's being
digested and i'm like ah it's not gross
but
thinking about it is like kind of [ __ ]
up
so he but he got that from the blob yeah
i think yeah but like if so he gets
eaten but then well the dumb thing is
that the professor i kind of feel like
the professor should have got eaten by
the rap bat spider monster which is
awesome i really do like that monster
like the look of it like i said it was
just some cheap [ __ ] puppet that they
made
but it looked cool like you could tell
it was a puppet obviously because like
it just moved like it was on a string
but i think like the red just all the
whole red filter and the whole look of
it like made it look really creepy they
had a face had little hands and stuff
you know so it kind of personality
they're
doing it it's a marionette it's probably
about that big around i think it was 14
inches or that's what i read yeah that's
i i heard that it was 14. yeah i mean
i'd have made several
creatures like that i had all kinds of
fun it had been a whole [ __ ] mars
movie
the movie that should have 90 of this
should have been on mars and the
survival horror
yeah and i mean like i said as soon as
they got to mars they should have got
their asses off the [ __ ] ship and
started exploring stuff because that's
what you would do like why would you go
all the way to mars and then dig around
in the space ship like playing cards
that's what the audience wants to see or
reading comedy books like they want to
dive into the [ __ ] and really show an
audience what they wanted to see for
some reason they just they didn't think
that way
they're making like well well we have to
work if we do that that's like yeah well
[ __ ] show us some marionettes well
maybe they got maybe the guys making it
where you know back in my day when we
had to walk three miles uphill like in
the snow like for movies we didn't
nothing happened nothing happened
now you want everything to happen
yeah that's maybe that's what it was
yeah maybe she's like here you go here's
your monster [ __ ] off nothing happened
in our movies god damn it well one thing
i did want to say is that i was kind of
bummed out that like okay so you know
brooklyn jay leno gets absorbed by the
blob which is great i mean you know but
um he got eaten by one of the monsters i
think it would have been better if the
professor professor van dyke beard or
professor devil as we were calling him
yeah um even though he was a nice man
but he kind of looked like the devil i
kind of wish that he had been eaten by
the rat bat spider monster because the
rap bat spider monster didn't really he
got blinded but he didn't eat anybody he
was just kind of like there and he got
he was trying to eat him yeah but the
professor just like died of a heart
attack right like on the ship yeah i
guess so didn't he yeah because
everything was just too much for him
because he was like an older guy and
he's just like i can't take it
you know what i mean it's funny and i
was just kind of like yeah you had all
those monsters come on why did it pop
his head off or somebody was in 1959
they're going to shoot him popping his
head off but you know what i mean you
could have like at least had the monster
they didn't have a technology to have
the puppet eat anybody eating anybody
that's true it would have looked it
would have looked really bad
i mean they could have just implied they
could have like put him over like that
had the guy go ah and then like you cut
away like oh god he popped his head off
that's what they would have done in the
50s you know what i mean that's budget
[ __ ] i you know i know that but uh yeah
so i kind of feel like that i was
another thing i was going to say too
when you were talking about like the
whole bitch's be crazy thing back then
the first time that you see a monster
which we haven't talked about like the
the kind of bipedal monster that looks
kind of like
kind of like a kind of like a damn
bipedal uh what is that you know frog at
a crustacean yeah it's kind of like
interesting three-eyed crawfish so you
see him briefly like outside the
spaceship's window like not long after
they get there like kind of going woo
and it's green
and uh iris because she's a woman even
though she's a scientist she screams and
like kind of passes out and [ __ ] and
then they're like she's like there was a
[ __ ] and she was kind of like just
trying to describe it like it was this
horrible face with like three eyes like
she described it pretty good and then
like the dude captain tom says to her oh
but there's nothing there now which
means that there was never anything
there yeah she was like it was right
[ __ ] there you know what i mean it
could have run away yeah i don't know
and i'm like yeah we're on an alien
planet there's nothing out there
right
you know there can't be anything out
there this is mars there's nothing out
there she was very fainty for a
scientist gotta say
but yeah so there was that oh and oh and
also there was a thing where she climbed
up to the top level of the spaceship
which is where the bunks were and there
was this big crash and everybody's like
what the [ __ ] was that and she's like oh
i'm so clumsy i fell and like you know
dropped a tray of test tubes or
something and that's that crash was like
oh women yeah you scientists you can't
even walk properly but it's like like i
said they did like there's some of that
in the movie but i've seen like way
worse examples like in 50s this was
actually like not too bad and like i
said at the end she actually is the one
that figures out because they have all
these people all these doctors and stuff
trying to figure out like when they got
captain tom back to earth like how to
get the blob [ __ ] off his arm
and she's the one that actually figures
out how to do it because the doctors are
like we don't know um but she's the one
that actually figures out how to do it
like to kill it with electroshock or
whatever the hell but she's the one that
figures it out so she does actually like
uh have kind of a part of it but we just
thought that was very funny uh but yeah
so this is actually we got the idea to
watch this because they just put it on
amazon prime not too long ago and you
cut you remembered it because you've
seen it with your dad and i was pretty
sure that i had never seen it
and i was kind of like that sounds kind
of cool and i remember i vaguely
remembered like hearing about the
gimmick about it like the cinemagic
thing where it was red and everything
and uh and i of course knew about the
cover of the misfits uh iconic 1982 walk
among us which has the rat bat spider
creature on it so if you ever wanted to
know where that monster's from it's from
angry red planet
but yeah so it's not like i said it's
not a great
50s sci-fi film um and it's pretty slow
like it takes a while like to get going
even though it's pretty short
but um it's actually once they get to
mars it's actually pretty cool like i
kind of had a good time with it you know
what i mean if you're in the mood for
50s
sci-fi
there are other ones you should see
first yeah this is one that you see if
you've seen the other ones yeah this
one's not like essential 50 sci-fi
viewing right
for 50s essential the very first one i'd
say probably war of the worlds
then right after that
you'd want to see
a forbidden planet
and then after that you'd want to see
the day the earth stood still
and then after that maybe the thing the
old 50s the thing yeah the thing from
another one from another world yeah
um
then maybe this one
yeah there might be some other ones
though you might want to see uh yeah
like i said i kind of feel like this
one's beer it's still pretty
entertaining yeah especially if you
really like the 50s sci-fi vibe and you
don't mind it being really slow
um and you like the gimmicks because i
really i kind of like the gimmicks i'm
not gonna lie i put the blob over this
yeah
yeah um
you know but
actually the gimmick in this one is
actually really good because i do think
that it looks
cool like when they go to mars and it's
like it really does look weird and like
otherworldly because it's like red and
that it's like [ __ ] hand-drawn
and you know the monsters are cool
looking and [ __ ] like that even though
they're obviously like really cheap but
i think they get did a good job with
what they had i think this only cost 200
000
yeah well [ __ ]
but yeah
it might have been a little bit more but
i remember robinson caruso on mars being
good that was the one where the guy he
shows up he's got a monkey and the
monkey's in a little spacesuit remember
yeah that's right and they're trying to
survive
he's drinking he's he he's he's
breathing the monkey's oxygen has a
little i remember that okay i did see
that one though yeah that's the same
director pretty sure that was that's the
same time
i remember liking it i don't remember
that's the only thing i remember about
it that was him sharing oxygen with it
with that watch that one again one of
these yes there's a lot of uh but yeah
this is definitely a good brc tier
uh you know 50 sci-fi it's a good time
we had a good time with it especially
like all the weird like sexual innuendo
yeah and the brooklyn jay leno guy like
with his weird ammo sexual thing yeah
with it with his gun cleo and i'm just
like
yeah is he gonna stick his dick in that
because i'm leaving that was that was
world war ii talking
that was kind of like some dude who's
[ __ ] glad to have been to been a
flamethrower man out there on [ __ ]
the aisle of [ __ ] iwo jima or [ __ ]
you know
during the island campaigns yeah it was
something like that but yeah it was
pretty entertaining i thought but yeah
so uh it's on amazon prime for free at
the moment if you want to watch it so uh
let me know what you guys thought about
it in the comments and we will see you
guys on the next one bye
you